intellectually I understand that all of
us are going to die that humanity will
perish and fall back into perfect
obscurity maybe not tomorrow or for a
million years but eventually all we ever
made will be dust and yet I keep making
things other than for the reason that
existential dread grips me only about
once a week and that I have a concern
for bettering my world along more modest
timescales I make things because those
things have intrinsic value to me that's
not a simple concept intrinsic value and
yet it's something we all assigned to
the things we love to do it's why we
love to do them because that activity is
valuable for its own sake writing
fiction that's something I do for its
own sake making music this channel the
nerd writer is intrinsically valuable to
me it combines my love of learning and
expression with the skills I've gained
in video editing over years and years
when I'm editing these blocks a process
that takes about four to six hours I
often find myself in a sort of super
focused state where it almost seems like
my awareness is merging with my actions
on the computer and the next thing I
know I'm feeling lightheaded because
hours have passed and I've completely
forgot to eat dinner and now it's 1:00
a.m. there's a psychological term for
this feeling and it's called flow it's a
concept introduced by Hungarian
psychology professor Mihai
Csikszentmihalyi when he became
fascinated by how artists got lost in
their work when Sheikh sent me I talked
to painters or athletes or scientists
they all described to him similar
feelings of heightened focus one
composer described it like this you are
in an ecstatic state to such a point
that you feel as though you almost don't
exist my hand seems devoid of myself and
I have nothing to do with what is
happening I just sit there in a state of
awe and wonder Minh and the music just
flows out of it it was this continual
reference to the image of being in a
river or water flowing that gave G
semi-high the name for his phenomenon
and it seems about as old as humanity is
historical sources suggest that
Michelangelo may have been in a state of
flow while painting
the Sistine Chapel it's reported that he
would paint four days at a time
forsaking food or sleep in the Tao of
Jeet Kune Do Bruce Lee instructs empty
your mind be formless shapeless like
water everyone can experience this
feeling but to do so requires a few
preconditions first you have to be
involved in an activity with the clear
set of goals and progress the task at
hand must have clear and immediate
feedback and most importantly there has
to be a good balance between the
perceived challenges of a task and one's
perceived skills Sheikh semi-high
developed a model for his idea and it
looks like this on the y-axis is the
challenge level and on the x-axis is the
skill level as you can see when the
challenge is really hard and the skills
are really low that's gonna cause
anxiety because you know what you want
to do but you can't even get close to
achieving any kind of representative
drawing fits that category for me only
when the challenge level is high and you
have the skills to match can a state of
flow be achieved the composure I quoted
above had been working at his craft for
decades the process was second nature
tip a pro athlete who gets in the zone
another synonym for flow practices for
the balance of his life I've been video
editing for 10 years and because of all
those years of hard earned technique I
can see what I want to do like a
mechanic can see how the pieces of a car
should come together and like a mechanic
or a composer or an athlete I'm forced
to push myself into new territory
because the challenges eventually get
easier and I fall back into a state of
control when writing fiction I waver
somewhere between arousal and anxiety
it'll be many more years I suspect
before my talent matches the gargantuan
task of writing and I can slip into that
space where the mutinous nest of my
thoughts resolves into the lovely shapes
I admire in other writers the key point
here is that flow is possible in so many
areas of experience art science sports
at work in business or law or medicine
but it's vital prerequisite in all those
cases
is an extended devotion to crap we all
have the ability to distinguish between
different qualities of pleasure being in
a flow state seems to me to be made of
pure stuff not just for what it achieves
but for what it is I don't know why
human beings can experience intrinsic
value in the activities that they choose
to love but I'm happy to go along for
the ride
so since I've been back from my last
little break we've talked about Beach
Wales comic book films Keane sugi the
Diderot effect how nuclear weapons
screwed art forgers video games
architecture the right to be forgotten
and now flow and the conversations and
discussions in the weeks following all
those videos have been more interesting
to me in most cases than the videos
themselves I want to thank everybody
who's been watching since I've been back
and engaging in these videos and these
topics I'm glad you're part of this
community if you're watching us thank
you for watching and engaging and
continue to do so I'm going to focus as
much as I can on you ask me anything on
tumblr where we can really sort of
expand on these topics or comment below
post this on reddit follow me on Twitter
for short little thoughts all that good
stuff I will see you next Friday